[Musique]
bonsoir les petits amis oh là là vous
avez bien manquer de ne pas nous voir ce
soir il y à une de ces circulations dans
le ciel et nous avons eu un mal fou pour
arriver jusque chez petit louis et
mirabel heureusement que vous m'avez pas
trop gros jour c'est un fin pilote et il
connaît bien son code de la route du
ciel mais que fondons nos deux petits
amis petit lou ye mirabel
je veux bien l'impression qu'ils ont eu
aussi du mal à circuler
je descends les guides et de mes
conseils mais ne traîne pas trop gros
ours ne fait pas attendre sur coton pas
pro pro
faites donc attention monsieur nounours
il faut traverser dans les passages
cloutés
sinon vous allez vous faire gober n'ont
joué très dangereux donc c'est
automobile re l'instant les enfants je
m'en vais régler cette circulation
[Musique]
et
nous allons alors la petite tape du
rebelle doublé tôt sur la gauche à ces
femmes toutes les mamans valant
chauffeuse mars à logrono ouest ont
choisi
alors les raisons
même les priorités monsieur mais je vais
appuyer le garde monsieur pas monsieur m
alors un orient au nom ou le lot que
l'en but love voyons voir des lèvres des
cloches il n'y a pas de blessés dreams
non jambon bon c'est l'essentiel
c'était faute collioure double car
n'avait déjà pas les mots je suis un
mauvais agents de police dit oui et
c'est tout à fois qu'il ya un accident
vous publiez sur tout autre bon agent de
police viennent bon je ne suis pas un
très bon agent de police et bam et
gaillard ou 2 go c'est que ça sent qu'un
don après son réchaud 20 sont pressants
à nous allons un ordi tu sais me nous
c'est pas tout aveu de fautes
ouais ouais mais tu viendra demain quand
même être très bon agent de police ah
oui bon alors à l'eau dormez vite je
viendrai de marque
jésus a dit nounours
à demain à demain mais chez l'agent de
police ont sorti aujourd'hui nouvelle tu
sais d'accident les pc tout ça fout quoi
[Musique]
et voilà les conducteurs qui conduisent
trop vite en toujours des accidents il
faut être prudent car on peut se faire
très mal
mais je suis sûr que vous faites tous
très attention aux n'avons pas trop le
feu est au vert
bonne nuit jean louis bonnet mirabel
connu des enfants à demain et pour lui
doucement gros zoom car nous avons
encore une longue tournée à fait
[Musique]
oh